[Music]
he's acknowledging that he should not
have been left alone that's Tyler Henry
connecting with Latoya Jackson's late
brother Michael Jackson on the season
finale of Hollywood media where we have
big questions basically the timeline
what took place during that particular
time that led to this Edie's dad I'm
Tyler and Latoya to learn all about the
experience everybody is curious to know
meeting my family now and outsiders as
well how was the transition and how are
things going I was really nervous yeah
because I didn't know what to expect I
didn't know who was gonna come through
because you can't always be sure that
the person that you want to come through
will come through it's kind of like a
feeling of like oh my god what I do I
don't wanna waste time like clearly
something's happening and this happens
very fast
I talked to Tyler before the season
aired and he said Michael came through
very childlike innocent so when you hear
that how do you feel
that's so Michael so Michael he was so
childlike very Ennis had just wanted
peace wanted love didn't want to talk
about anything that was disturbing so I
knew right away he just want to defuse
everything with joy and happiness
what did your family and his kids think
when you told them about this experience
and that you are gonna do this I have
mentioned it to anybody because you sign
this waiver so this is my first talking
about it exclusive these kids are gonna
be later definitely yes his daughter
will love to hear what went on and what
took place Michael died unexpectedly in
2009 of cardiac arrest lots of questions
followed about the circumstances
surrounding his death I just don't feel
like he had someone to like say hey I'm
having a medical emergency no one was
there to say that he mentioned that
there was a deep personal connection
between him and Parris especially what
do you make of that I think he's
absolutely right yeah absolutely because
he's always watching over her I believe
to make sure that she's on the right
proper path because he used to say
things before that okay if something
happens to me make sure you watch over
Paris cuz Paris has a personality she
loves the business but I want to make
sure she's okay yes and she's a good
person she has a look that she has heart
like her father she has a good heart
which is really really really great
because that's hard to find I truly I
believe that Paris can do whatever she
wants because the talent is there and
she wants it and when you want something
bad enough you're you do it yeah I could
take nothing of it he just comes natural
to her but it's it's like Michael he was
the most famous person in the world but
you would never know that at home
because he didn't look at it that way
parecer or prints or blankets like what
is the time like with you and with them
they're just blankets Wheatley's do he's
being a kid just whatever you want yeah
just play games enjoy cuz we like to
play games for family weeklies blood
playing games we make sure all the kids
are involved and give them their turn
Cody yeah cheer them on and make them
feel great and happy like it's your turn
to draw and they love it I think that's
what keeps a family its innocence
together
[Music]
knowing what he's told you what have you
done with that message I'm very pleased
because if blot it brought closure and
validation which which we all want when
you lose a loved one
there's it you're helpless there's
nothing you could do absolutely nothing
you can't bring that individual back but
he helped me a great deal and now I
understand this he was telling me that
he's okay he's fine he's doing well he's
content and it was an easy transition
what do you hope that the family takes
away when they watch the episode I hope
that they they're able to watch it
they're able to see what Tyler does and
they're able to say to themselves okay I
got it I understand it now this is
closure
Galvis
[Music]